[Música]
Y qué se Comenta en otros medios
internacionales Justo eso es lo que
vamos a ver en la revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Marta Buenos días bienvenida
Hola María Clara Buenos días empecemos
en Estados Unidos donde se despertó la
polémica luego de conocerse que dos
niños de 10 años estaban trabajando en
la madrugada en una hamburguesería que
además es una cadena multinacional que
nos dice la bbc al respecto Marta sí
María Clara nos referimos a la empresa
McDonald's esa semana conocimos que dos
niños de 10 años estaban trabajando en
esta franquicia en Louisville en la
capital de Kentucky y por ello
McDonald's tendrá que pagar
200.000 dólares de multa no solo allí
sino porque se han reportado que hasta
300 menores estarían trabajando en
franquicias de esta cadena de
hamburguesas estas prácticas se han dado
concretamente en 62 locales de McDonald
en los estados de Kentucky Indiana
Maryland y Ohio entre las causas de las
sanciones a esta cadena multinacional
están que los menores estaban trabajando
más de las tres horas permitidas por la
ley federal porque Estados Unidos no
prohíbe el trabajo adolescente sino que
lo regula los menores trabajaban como
cualquier otro tipo de trabajador no
hacían y se encargaban de las comandas
manejaban la caja registradora y también
limpiaban el local el escándalo creció
cuando no solo se reportaron en otros
estados estadounidenses sino que había
niños de 10 años trabajando a las 2 de
la madrugada en un establecimiento de
McDonald's además según la franquicia
esos niños eran los hijos del gerente
nocturno de ese local en concreto sin
embargo no era del todo así y además
desde McDonald's sostienen que estas
prácticas son
preocupante así profundamente
inaceptables según un estudio del
departamento de trabajo estadounidense
solo en 2022 María Clara
688 menores trabajaban bajo condiciones
ilegales de trabajo impresionante este
número marzo del que usted nos habla y
también increíble la cantidad de horas
trabajar como un adulto normal pero este
trabajo infantil no solo se reporta en
los estados que usted ya mencionó sino
que también hay casos en Iowa sí María
Clara y muy preocupante porque hay agua
se ha sumado a la lista de Estados
estadounidenses que van a revertir las
protecciones laborales para con Los
menores esto lo anunciado a la
gobernadora de Iowa Kim Reynolds que va
a llevar a cabo un proyecto de ley que
permita a los niños de hasta 14 años que
trabajen en labores como construcción
demolición venta de fuegos artificiales
o venta de alcohol mientras estos
trabajos forman parte de programas
educativos y además tengan el
consentimiento de sus tutores legales
además se permitiría estos adolescentes
de hasta 14 años trabajar más horas como
cualquier otro adulto según las
autoridades de Iowa con este nuevo
proyecto de ley se levantan textualmente
restricciones innecesarias a menores que
quieran trabajar para salir adelante en
la vida o ahorrar dinero para ir a la
universidad usted ya lo mencionó que el
trabajo infantil no está prohibido sino
regulado en Estados Unidos pero hay una
tendencia Y es que en los Estados
dominados Por los republicanos quieren
flexibilizar cada vez más el trabajo
infantil que reportes hay al respecto
Marta Sí hemos destacado a María Clara
un análisis de boxcom que dice que los
últimos 10 años perdón dos años diez
estados la mayoría de cortes republicano
se han sumado a esta flexibilización de
la protección de trabajo de menores la
justificación es que no hay mano de obra
suficiente y por ello quieren flexi las
horas y los trabajos a los que se pueden
sumar estos adolescentes recientemente
en Wisconsin también se aprobó un
proyecto de ley para permitir a los
menores de hasta 14 años servir al con
el alcohol en restaurantes o bares y
también otros estados como New Jersey
Arkansas Nebraska también han llevado a
cabo medidas semejantes en los últimos
dos años como decíamos el Gobierno
Federal regula el empleo bajo una ley de
1938 llamada ley de normas laborales
justas prohíbe el trabajo infantil
opresivo pero por ejemplo permite que un
menor trabaje en cualquier trabajo
mientras la empresa sea de sus padres
también permite que menores de 14 años
trabajen repartiendo periódicos cuidando
a otros niños o en la actuación y
también permite que Durante los meses de
verano los menores de hasta 14 años
trabajen hasta las 9 de la noche
mientras en el período escolar hasta se
permite hasta las 7 de la noche y con la
actitud ha llevado a innumerables
problemas que ahora se ven acrecentados
con estas medidas que toman sobre todo
estado republicanos de flexibilizar las
restricciones o las condiciones
laborales de menores de edad pero
Incluso en medio de esa regularización
los más vulnerables son los más
afectados de hecho el New York Times
esta semana hablaba de Cómo afecta el
trabajo infantil principalmente a los
menores migrantes si María Clara y aquí
es donde la cosa ya se pone más fea no
porque ya hace unos meses el New York
Times hacía una investigación en la que
denunciaba que los menores no
acompañados migrantes son las víctimas
más afectadas por esta lacra No desde
hace dos años sostiene este artículo del
neor Times que hemos destacado han
llegado al país más de 250.000 menores
no acompañados que a menudo trabajan en
labores como mataderos cambiando tejados
de edificios operando maquinarias
pesadas
y pues todos estos trabajos vulneran las
leyes federales sin embargo estas
advertencias continuas que se han hecho
tanto desde medios de comunicación como
desde otros informes independientes han
llegado a la casa blanca pero no han
motivado a que el Gobierno Federal tome
medidas de calado para regular la
situación de los migrantes no
acompañados que como decimos son las
víctimas de esta lacra del trabajo
laboral infantil los informes llegaban a
la casa blanca pero no se clasificaban
como urgentes entonces Las
investigaciones no prosperaban Y tenemos
a grupos de niños migrantes que
trabajaban incluso con
industrias o productos químicos
cáusticos Así que una lacra totalmente
injustificada que denunciaba New York
Times y gracias a usted Por traer este
tema a colación le propongo que
cambiemos radicalmente y nos vayamos a
Reino Unido porque mañana sábado en la
madrugada hora latinoamericana será la
coronación de Carlos tercero Qué hay al
respecto si hemos destacado María Clara
un artículo delgarian que dice que la
ceremonia de la coronación de la
coronación Perdón va a estar plagada de
simbolismo histórico vamos a ver joyería
real una vara corta de oro con una
pequeña Cruz vamos a ver la piedra del
destino la espada de la Misericordia o
los brazaletes de la sinceridad y la
sabiduría y dice de Guardian que si bien
esta ceremonia puede parecer anacrónica
para una audiencia del siglo XXI es muy
importante todo este simbolismo para Los
Monarcas la unción dice textualmente de
Guardián ni la unción con aceite ni el
solemne juramento de coronación son
Realmente necesarios pero forman parte
de la historicidad que supone este
evento y de seguir con la tradición en
Reino Unido además hemos destacado Por
otra parte una editorial que dice que la
coronación es un desfile anticuado que
debe repensarse ya no es una coronación
ni para subrayar la potencia mundial que
Reino Unido ni siquiera una oda al
simbolismo nacional sino que se lleva a
cabo por anacrónica razones religiosas y
constitucionales eso dice la editorial
de de Garden Y por último hemos
destacado un artículo del país que dice
que el reinado de Carlos III va a marcar
una diferencia muy clara con el reinado
de su madre Isabel II e Isabel II por
ejemplo
marcándose marcando muy bien su posición
en temas como medio ambiente las
desigualdades sociales y económicas en
Reino Unido y también
destacando el pasado esclavista de la
corona británica que Carlos III ha dicho
que va a estar a favor de que se investi